I don't think that the only thing I'm
buying is you know probably just gotta
watch out for the cheap shots and the
dirty bits and all the things that he
likes to teach that's that's pretty much
all we gotta watch out for other than
that I expect the same to high safety I
don't expect much man to me and I expect
none of that I mean I if I was a coach I
would never teach what he teaches but
that's just him and what he does so
there's no room getting under my skin
anymore
that's Odell Beckham jr. with comments
about Jets defensive coordinator Greg
Williams who had been the defensive
coordinator and interim head coach in
Cleveland and it was two years ago in
August when the Giants played in
Cleveland big cat for a preseason game
that Odell Beckham jr. suffered a
sprained ankle eventually a broken leg
during the regular season that's what
he's referring to Greg Williams then the
defensive coordinator in Cleveland had
his players go after Beckham in a
preseason game and this is the key to me
and this is the thing that I think cries
out for something more investigation or
something by the NFL because Beckham
said this I had players on this team
telling me that that's what he was
telling them to do now I thought all
this went away with the bounty scanner
when I know the bounty scandal focused
on offering guys money to try to
incapacitate opponents but still if you
have a coach who is telling his players
to try to incapacitate opponents that
becomes a problem that becomes an issue
if you're watching on TV a guy going in
low a guy going in hot on Odell Beckham
jr. and injuring that leg I have a
feeling this is not the end but just the
beginning with Odell Beckham jr.
speaking out hold on Mike you said you
just told me that you thought this all
went away with Greg Williams with the
bounty gate and everything you thought
that Greg Williams would change the type
of football coach he is come on grow up
grow up Mike of course Greg Williams is
still doing this I don't think it's
right I think it's actually very bad but
Greg Williams has been coaching football
for however long it's been decades and
decades and decades he coaches in a
specific style
he's been basically coaching for every
single team in the NFL it feels like he
rubs people the wrong way and he has
guys go out there and try to hurt the
opponent I mean that's just what when
you get Greg Williams on your defense
when you have him
your defense you have to know that
that's probably gonna happen he's also
probably gonna coach them to coach them
up and play an aggressive style of
defense that does well and gets results
but that's part of the equation here
when you're talking about Gregg Williams
well look he wouldn't be in the NFL
again after everything that went down in
the bounty scandal including him
submitting an affidavit saying that
Jonathan Vilma did indeed offer $10,000
to anyone who knocked Brett Favre out of
the NFC Championship game a decade ago I
thought he was done at that point I
thought that was a bridge he could not
walk back across but he is a good coach
here's the thing though since he's been
back he hasn't been accused of this kind
of stuff we haven't heard the cartoonish
quotes like he had in the locker room
before the 49ers and the Saints played
in the playoffs several years ago and he
was talking about kill the head and the
body will die and go after Frank Gore
and go after this and go after that that
has not resurfaced until now so I didn't
know whether he was behaving or whether
he was just being very discreet it
sounds like he was being very discreet
but apparently not discreet enough
because it got back to Odell Beckham jr.
and now apparently Williams due to meet
with the media on Friday he's not the
kind of guy that you're gonna scare into
not going after you I don't know what
OBJ's strategy is in bringing this to
light three days before a game against
Greg Williams but it's not gonna get
Greg Williams to back down no you're
right Greg Williams will definitely take
this personally whether he did it or not
he will take it personally and he will
look for revenge with his scheming and
and his defense and I think it's I lean
more to the discrete side Mike I think
Greg Williams has a style that he's
gonna coach it's an aggressive style he
gets a lot out of his players and he get
in and he gets players to you know hit
the opponent in in a physical way that
you don't always see with defensive
coordinators you see some teams they
don't you know they don't gang tackle
the same way as other teams you see some
teams don't have that physical presence
that Greg Williams defenses do have so
it probably wasn't overt but it
definitely has still been going on and
Odell Beckham coming out and saying this
is no surprise to me and baquette this
is one of the great disconnects in
football because there are strategic
advance
is to be gained by incapacitating key
members of the opposing team with clean
legal hits sam donaldson capacitated by
mono that helps the Browns if someone
else can't play if Le'Veon Bell
ultimately has a setback with his
shoulder and can't play that helps the
Browns and Browns defensive players I
guarantee you will be testing the
shoulder of Le'Veon Bell because if you
can test it in a way that causes it to
fail that is an advantage to the Browns
that's part of football and clean legal
hits that will cause the opponent to not
be able to play that's been part of the
game since they first invented it right
get the best players off the field any
way you can as long as you stay within
the boundaries of the rules but nobody's
allowed to talk about that anymore I
mean it's just a weird it's a weird
reality where it is part of the game but
you know what if you embrace that Jimmy
and Johnny aren't gonna be allowed to
play by mom and dad and I think the NFL
tries to stay away from that as much as
they can but here it is front and center
again thanks to Odell Beckham jr. yeah I
agree and Greg Williams is an old-school
coach who coaches in a different manner
from a different era of the NFL and
that's that's kind of my bigger point is
Greg wasn't gonna change he's not gonna
all of a sudden become a new type of
coach he's learned football a certain
way he's gonna coach football a certain
way and this is going to be part of
football until the Greg Williams era
type guys are long and got long gone I
thought when he went shoe polishing the
goatee that meant he had changed would
you do that would you do shoe polish no
that means he's guilty when you change
your hair or anything you know that's
usually a sign of guilt more happens
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports